voilà vous l'avez vu mercredi soir les
sénateurs ont donc adopté l'article 4 du
projet de loi renforçant les moyens de
la lutte contre le terrorisme
un article qui prévoit de faire basculer
l'apologie et la provocation au
terrorisme de la loi sur la presse de
1881 au code pénal ce qui permet de
poursuivre et bien ces abus avec les
moyens de la lutte contre le terrorisme
à noter les sénateurs ont adopté ce
texte dans la version de la commission
qui se focalise sur l'apologie et la
provocation au terrorisme sur internet
une focalisation sur la toile qui se
justifie selon le rapporteur socialiste
et ump par l'effet démultiplicateur du
web
tout de suite on passe à un autre
article qui a également été adopté par
les sénateurs s'étaient jeudi matin
l'article 5 qui crée le délit d'
entreprises individuelles terroristes
mes chers collègues l'ordre du jour
appelle la suite de la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée renforçant les
dispositions relatives à la lutte contre
le terrorisme dans la discussion des
articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'article 5
donc je suis saisi d'un amendement
l'amendement numéro 62 de madame la
présidente
a phase i et ses collègues qui défend
l'amendement
madame kerman vous avez la parole le
dame la présidente monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues nous demandons à
travers cet amendement la suppression de
l'article 5 puisque dans ce
projet de loi il semblerait que la
réaction au terrorisme n'est qu'affaire
d'incrimination il s'agit finalement de
saisir une réalité qui nous semble à ce
jour encore et nous en avons débattu
hier soir peu étayés de lui apporter une
traduction juridique par une
qualification qui se veut adapté cet
article 5 introduit l'incrimination
entreprises terroristes individuels
alors que notre arsenal répressif autres
arts l'association de malfaiteurs dans
le contexte du terrorisme répondez à nos
yeux par extension à cette situation
mais à travers cet article
il nous semble qu'il ait finalement
construit sur une c'est là pour nous en
tout cas un danger qui les construit sur
une logique qui se traduit
inévitablement par la pénalisation
effective d intention éventuelle sans
qu'il y ait ça qu'il n'y ait même pas le
commencement d'exécution juridiquement
requis pour établir si la loi a
effectivement été enfreintes
comme le souligne un certain nombre
d'ailleurs d'associations dès lors nous
pensons que pénaliser des intentions
exprimées parfois même dans la solitude
sans attendre le commencement
d'exécution juridiquement requis pour
caractériser une tentative est une
évolution dangereuse et cela ne suffit
ni à exclure les risques de dérives ni à
convaincre de l'efficacité de telles
dispositions face à des individus ça a
été dit et je crois par l'ensemble et au
moins nous entendons tous sont ce là des
individus par essence difficilement
identifiables voire même maîtrisable
dans l'anticipation de leurs faits et
gestes en l'état pour nous le droit
pénal doit rester limités par les bornes
clairement identifié que sont la
légalité et la proportionnalité légal
dignité la présomption d'innocence c'est
pourquoi à travers cet amendement nous
vous proposons la suppression de
l'article 5
merci ma chère collègue l'avis de la
commission merci madame la presse cet
article est quand même un des articles
les plus importants du projet de loi
puisque contrairement à ce que vous avez
dit ma chère collègue l'association de
malfaiteurs et c'est ça ne joue pas
quand c'est les entreprises
individuelles terroristes et c'est
justement le problème c'est l'auto 2
égalisation d'un certain nombre de
personnes qui ensuite et bien d'autres
quand vous dites y'a pas de l'égalité
c'est parfaitement encadré il ya des
dispositifs qui doivent eux il ya une
intention
il ya des préparatifs il ya aussi des
éléments matériels et donc ce cet
article là en plus tels que améliorée
par la l'assemblée puis par notre
commission vise à rendre à la fois
effectifs mais avec toutes les garanties
de droit et donc je ne peux être
favorable à la suppression de cet
article
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
la vie du gouvernement bien madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais profiter de cet
amendement pour apporter quelques
précisions sur la volonté qu'a eue le
gouvernement de mettre en place cette
nouvelle incrimination pénale
nous avons en effet souhaité avec la
création du délit d'entreprises
individuelles terroriste adapter le
droit à l'évolution du phénomène
terroriste qui s'est considérablement
atomisé au cours des dernières années
ces terroristes repose maintenant sur
des cellules parfois réduites à leur
plus simple expression puisqu'il peut
s'agir d'un individu seul celui ci peut
avoir suivi un entraînement sur un
théâtre d'opérations terroristes et être
renvoyés après avoir subi ou suivi cet
entraînement sur notre sol avec pour
mission de passer à l'acte sans
entretenir de relations continues avec
ses commanditaires
il peut également suivre des mots
d'ordre généraux des appels au meurtre
relayée sur les sites internet radicaux
et agir de lui même ces individus
représente un danger incontestable
au niveau opérationnel résolument les
rend difficilement détectables au niveau
juridique le projet criminel ne peut
résulter d'un échange matérialisant une
association
existe par conséquent des cas qui
n'entre pas dans la catégorie de
l'association de malfaiteurs en lien
avec une entreprise terroriste
il nous faut donc et les juges
antiterroristes ont eux mêmes souligné
cette nécessité définir l'entreprise
individuelle terroristes de manière
suffisamment précise pour éviter de
pénaliser un comportement quelconque et
en même temps suffisamment souple pour
lui permettre d'embrasser un champ
suffisamment large il reprochait aux
délits d'entreprises individuelles
terroristes c'est un peu l'esprit de
votre amendement de laisser au juge la
possibilité de condamner une simple
intention de confier aux magistrats une
mission de neutralisation préventive
pour reprendre l'expression imagée du
syndicat de la magistrature
en premier lieu le délit d'association
de malfaiteurs en droit commun existe
depuis longtemps depuis 1810 très
exactement le législateur a donc compris
depuis longtemps l'intérêt qu'il y avait
à intervenir en amont pour ne pas
laisser se perpétrer les faits les plus
graves en matière de terrorisme
l'association de malfaiteurs terroristes
est la pierre angulaire du dispositif ce
délit est utilisé quotidiennement par
les magistrats et enquêteurs spécialisés
c'est cette incrimination qui permet les
condamnations des terroristes avant le
passage à l'acte et qui permet en effet
nous l'assumons une neutralisation
préventive de leurs projets criminels
l'infraction d'obstacles d'association
de malfaiteurs terroristes
si elle n'a pas été validée en tant que
tel par le conseil constitutionnel a été
indirectement examiner et reconnu au
moins à trois reprises madame la
sénatrice par le conseil constitutionnel
en 1996 en 2004 et en 2010 la
pénalisation des actes préparatoires
n'est donc pas par principe contraire à
la constitution et la définition de
l'entreprise terroristes individuels et
conforme au principe de légalité des
délits et des peines
dès lors que le champ de l'incrimination
est précisément déterminées et que les
éléments matériels sont précisément
défini l'entreprise individuelle
terroristes ne visera pas à pénaliser
une simple intention là aussi
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
souvent élire mais bien un projet
terroriste une ferme résolution
objectivée par des faits matériels dont
et j'insiste sur ce point la possession
de moyens dangereux
associé à d'autres comportements dans le
cas du jeune militaire d'extrême droite
sur le point de commettre un attentat
contre une mosquée la possession légale
de moyens dangereux et le suivi
d'entraînement était caractérisée de
même que sa détermination qui était
matérialisée par un courrier adressé un
camarade où il lui faisait part de son
projet funeste fallait-il dès lors
laisser faire
le délit d' entreprise individuelle
terroristes se compose donc se décompose
donc de la manière suivante d'abord
l'élément moral
il est nécessaire de démontrer
l'existence chez la personne poursuivie
d'un projet criminel celui de commettre
un ou des actes terroristes parmi les
plus graves atteintes à la vie en lève
mans séquestration détournement
d'aéronef destruction par explosif
empoisonnement deuxièmement l'élément
matériel qui peut consister dans des
dérapages des antes des repérages des
entraînements à ses jours sur un théâtre
d'opérations terroristes
l'apprentissage du pilotage de la
conduite de certains types de véhicules
la consultation habituelle de sites
apologétique ou provocants au terrorisme
la recherche ou l'acquisition de moyens
logistiques en vue de commettre un
attentat
le gouvernement propose à ce dernier
sujet un amendement permettant
d'améliorer encore la rédaction des
rapporteurs
à cette liste doivent obligatoirement
s'ajouter la recherche
l'acquisition la fabrication ou la
détention d'armes ou de substances
dangereuses
vous voyez bien madame la sénatrice que
la réalisation d'un seul ou même de deux
de ces conditions ne suffit pas à
caractériser le
delhi prétendre le contraire il ya une
contre vérité
la consultation habituelle des sites les
plus odieux n'est pas pénalisée en
elle-même il s'agit d'un élément
matériel parmi d'autres dont
l'acquisition ou la détention d'un moyen
dangereux nécessaire pour kkr à
caractériser le délit d' entreprise
individuelle terroristes al'inverse si
l'on devait exiger le cumul de la
totalité de ses éléments pour ouvrir les
poursuites pénales et diligenté une
enquête comme le propose
madame la sénatrice à ça si l'action de
la police et de la justice serait
totalement paralysé c'est bien la
méthode du faisceau qui est retenue qui
permettra aux juges de se forger une
conviction le juge judiciaire dont on
nous a expliqué hier qu'il était le
garant de toutes les libertés
au vu des éléments de preuve qui lui
seront soumis et de motiver sa décision
car la mise en oeuvre de l'action
publique
l'instruction et le jugement de cette
infraction seront l'oeuvre de magistrats
de l'ordre judiciaire du siège et du
parquet dans le cadre de la procédure
pénale avec les garanties du procès
équitable
nous avons donc pris soin mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs d'aboutir à une
rédaction précise pour respecter le
principe de légalité des délits et des
peines est suffisamment large pour
garantir l'adaptation du texte aux
nouvelles formes de terrorisme c'est la
raison pour laquelle après ces
explications très détaillées que j'ai
fourni et qui m'apparaissent très
honnêtement endroit assez imparable
je serai très sensible à la mpt la
sénatrice est ce que vous retiriez votre
amendement merci monsieur le ministre je
vais mettre donc aux voix l'amendement
62 de suppression de l'article qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement
y at il des explications de vote
monsieur mercier
je vous remercie madame la présidente
naturellement je votre écoute la
brunante suppressions qui vient d'être
soutenu mais je voulais à bercy le
ministre de l'intérieur et qui vient de
définir de façon très précise il un
crime une incrimination pénale
il appartient bien entendu au parlement
puisqu'il s'agit d'une incrimination
pénale de décider ou non de cette
nouvelle accréditation de préciser et de
donner à l'état les moyens d'agir et à
la justice la seule petite question que
je me pose est fait et le ministère de
la justice dans cette affaire
autre explication de vote je n'en vois
pas je mets donc qu'aux voix
l'amendement de suppression numéro un
monsieur le ministre je sais pas ce
qu'il ya derrière la question de ces du
sénateur mercier qui connaît bien le
ministère de la justice pour l'avoir
dirigé mais que les choses soient bien
claires ce texte est porté par le
ministère de l'intérieur
il contient des dispositions qui ont été
validées en réunion interministérielle
et flo ont fait l'objet de discussions
extrêmement profond 10 entre la garde
des sceaux et moi même et bien entendu
toutes les dispositions de ce texte qui
ont vocation à être appliquée par
l'administration de la justice qui
dépend de madame le garde des sceaux
sont appliquées conformément à l'esprit
de la loi et il y as entre la
chancellerie et le ministère de
l'intérieur
non seulement un accord complet mais une
osmose parfaite
il n'ya plus d'explications de vote mais
aux voix qui est pour de genre et
d'autres qui est contre l'amendement
il n'est pas adopté je ne vois pas
l'abstention n'est pas adapté
je suis saisi de deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 46 de madame
benbassa vous avez la parole un collègue
merci madame la présidente
dans sa rédaction actuelle l'article 5
prévoit que constitue un acte de
terrorisme
le fait de préparer la commission d'un
acte de terrorisme notamment lorsque
cette préparation est caractérisée par
le fait de détenir de rechercher de se
procurer ou de fabriquer des objets ou
des substances de nature à créer un
danger pour autrui
l'objet de cet amendement est d'une part
de supprimer
l'action de rechercher des comportements
dont l'incrimination est prévue par
l'article 5
en effet et comme le souligne la cncdh
ce terme je cite évoque une conduite vol
imprécise car si tu es trop en amont du
commencement d'exécution de l'infraction
fin de l'incitation au contraire
l'action de détenir de se procurer ou de
fabriquer implique une vraie matérialité
dont le lien avec le projet terroriste
peut être établie il s'agit d'autre part
du président 6 et que les objets aux
substances doivent être de nature à
présenter un danger grave pour autrui
la notion de danger simple est un effet
trop vague et peut s'appliquer à un
nombre trop important d'objets et de
substances merci
l'amendement 63 qui est défendu par
madame kerman oui je crois très
rapidement parce que ça va dans le même
sens que je crois qu'on vient d'avoir un
échange avec avec monsieur le ministre
à travers cet article et finalement cet
amendement comme le suivant pour mon
groupe même s'ils ne sont pas mis en
discussion comme et sont dans le même
objectif qui vise à réduire en tout cas
mieux formuler apporter des garanties à
cet article 5 qui je l'excusent monsieur
le ministre vous vous éléments ne
semblent pas complètement imparable et
en tout cas vise à reprendre la logique
que j'ai évoqués précédemment
je crois que nous avons un réel une
réelle inquiétude donc forcément
ça a été le débat de la discussion
générale nous ne sommes pas forcément je
partage le même constat de la
dangerosité d'un certain nombre d'actes
aujourd'hui de par le monde et du danger
compris pour le devenir de nos jeunes
pour un certain nombre de personnes qui
skie qui sont les plus jeunes ni
apportons pas les mêmes les mêmes
réponses et partant de là
je crois que même si chacun et ça ici de
préserver un équilibre n'ayant pas les
mêmes objectifs et les réponses
même si je crois que personne ne les
cautionne nous ne nous retrouvons pas en
tout cas dans vos arguments monsieur le
ministre et à travers cet article 5 je
le redis cette volonté de nouvelles
incriminations
nous semble pas être
répond ni eux
au aux entreprises individuelles qui se
développe aujourd'hui et dans tout le
monde s'entend à dire mais je l'ait déjà
évoqué tout à l'heure quelles sont de
toute façon dans des formes de
fonctionnement de réaction complètement
nouvelle et peut-être même difficilement
anticipable même avec les différents
critères que vous évoquez et que dès
lors cet article 5 nous interroge sur le
fait que par une interprétation qui
pourrait l'étendre à d'autres
d'autres faits pourraient
réduire entre guillemets une partie des
libertés
je vais demander l'avis de la commission
oui d'amendements obtempérait de
modification à l'article 2 5 voulait
supprimer la mention du fait de
rechercher des substances dangereuses et
vous prévoyez que dangers causés par ses
six ans doit être grave
concernant le premier point l'acte de
rechercher bien faits concrets matériel
qui sera apprécié par les juges
alors moi c'est et concernant second
point la notion de graves dangers la
joute sans doute pas beaucoup à celle de
danger car je rappelle en plus qui avait
un certain nombre de conditions aussi
qu'il faut ajouter un des éléments
matériels donc pour toutes ces raisons
je suis défavorable à cet amendement et
à celui de madame benbassa également
puisque le caractère de gravité ne me
paraît pas apporté grand chose au à la
définition du délit ministre a vite dû
gouvernement gouvernement est exactement
du même avis que le rapporteur donc je
ne rajouterai rien sur ce point je vais
juste posé une question que le débat la
sénatrice on vous proposait un
amendement de suppression de ce cet
article et la question est simple quel
est le dispositif que vous préconisez
endroit pour faire face à la
comportement de ceux qui ces tentes
auto-radicalisés se propose de commettre
un crime ou un attentat sur le
territoire national en sachant que la
catégorie d' association de malfaiteurs
en lien avec une entreprise terroriste
dixit les juges antiterroristes ne
permet pas de traiter la situation de
ces personnes quelle est concrètement le
dispositif que vous proposez en
substitution de celui proposé par le
gouvernement
je vais mettre aux voix l'amendement 46
de madame benbassa qu'a reçu deux avis à
mais après de détourner quelques mots de
monsieur la seule explication date mais
pour justifier le vote du fait que j'ai
voté l'amendement madame benbassa et
donc ne pas partager l'avis du
gouvernement pense être dans les cadres
non mais je crois simplement on a déjà
il y avait un débat hier monsieur le
ministre je crois que ça a été dit par
un certain nombre d'orateurs
la réponse n'est pas simplement pénal
etc mais c'est là tout mais c'est là
toute la question en quelque sorte qui
fait qui fait que nous ne sommes pas que
nous sommes pas dans la même
appréciation
donc je crois voilà on peut reprendre
reprendre le débat
moi je reste par contre hâtivement
convaincu peut-être que l'avenir nous
donnera tort et tant mieux ou pas j'ai
envie de dire mais je pense et ça aussi
ça a été dit nous sommes face à des cons
partout des comportements pardo qui à
mon avis adapterons et dépasseront après
même là j'ai pas envie de dire avant
même mais dès promulgation fait de cette
loi un certain nombre de faits et le
contourneront parce qu'on le sait si la
question c'est y répondre à la barbarie
et au terrorisme tels qu'ils s'expriment
aujourd'hui dans une partie du monde
pouvait être simplement régler par par
ce texte là permettez moi monsieur me
sens en rabattre sur le travail qui a
été fait de dire je pense que ce sera un
peu trop simple et est certainement
trop facile donc voilà je crois qu'on en
est à ce carrefour là je pense
personnellement que ce texte ne répondra
ne résoudra pas tout et en disant cela
je ne dis pas que ce n'est pas fait les
bonnes réponses et que vous allez
laisser courir encore ce qui se passe et
que vous cautionnez ce qui se passe dans
certaines parties du monde
je crois que personne en tout cas sur
les bancs de mon groupe on a dit ça de
ce texte
nous pensons aujourd'hui que c'est pas
la bonne réponse alors après utilisons
bon la procédure d'urgence a été déclaré
donc nous n'aurons peut-être pas
suffisamment temps peut-être qu'avec un
peu plus de temps plus des changes nous
aurions pu aboutir c'est autre chose
mais je crois que la question n'est pas
de trouver un aboutissement
nous ne sommes pas forcément am logique
pour appréhender le problème et y
répondre donc voilà il ya un certain
nombre de dar d'articles d'amendements
sur lesquels nous ne sommes pas d'accord
et je vous propose d' acte et 7 ses
positions sofia a ré ouvrira les débats
pour chaque article monsieur le ministre
aucun problème pour ma part y at il
d'autres explications de vote
je n'en vois pas je mets aux voix qui
est pour de qui et contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 63 de madame
madame pic herrmann y at il des
explications de vote
je rappelle qu'il a eu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement je n'en vois pas je mets
aux voix qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
passons à l'amendement numéro 64 de
madame assassi et de ses collègues que
vous avez la parole il est défendu avis
de la commission dans votre objet même
que keur mame vous évoquez l'article 224
1 du code de sécurité intérieure je
pense qu'elle a eu un petit un petit
déplacement des explications puisqu'il
s'agit en fait de la côte de l'article
121 de 6 du code pénal mais votre
amendement tend à rendre cumulatif les
éléments prévus aux quatre alinéas 9 10
et 11 9 10 11 et 12 du de l'arctique la
nécessité d'un tel cumul rendrait
d'infraction inopérantes
il est en effet peu probable qu'une
personne qui a l'intention de commettre
des actes terroristes se livrent
cumulativement aux quatre types
d'activités listés par présent article
donc c'est un avis défavorable avec
également même avis je vais mettre aux
voix y at il des explications de vote
je n'en vois pas qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté je suis
saisi d'un amendement numéro 75 présenté
par le gouvernement vous avez la parole
ce ministre
lien il s'agit d'un amendement presque
rédactionnelle et comportements visé
s'analysant comme des agissements la
notion des deux faits matériels déjà
présent dans la définition de
l'association de malfaiteurs doit être
substituée à celle d'éléments matériels
merci monsieur minute servi de la
commission favorable s'étale amendements
rédactionnels qui n'appelle à priori pas
d'explications de vote je mets aux voix
s'il n'y a pas d'opposition
il n'y a pas de position il est adopté
je vous remercie amendement numéro 11 de
madame boulet women président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues il
s'agit simplement d'un amendement de
précision qui vise donc à préciser que
cet article ne s'applique pas donc sauf
lorsque il s'agit d'entraînement ou de
la formation qui résulte de l'exercice
normal d'une profession je voudrais
juste profité de la présentation de cet
amendement pour dire que en matière de
terrorisme et pour y travailler un peu
depuis plusieurs mois et on va être dans
la guerre de l'eau bue et du blindage
c'est à dire qu'au fur et à mesure qu'on
aura des législations les gens qui
voudront à la fois la détourner et à la
fois s'attaquer à notre république aux
principes de la démocratie trouveront
d'autres d'autres principes donc cet
article 5 peut poser des problèmes et on
en a on en a parlé longuement lors de la
discussion générale et je comprends tout
à fait les hésitations que les uns et
les autres pouvons avoir sur la
pénalisation des intentions mais en
l'espèce il s'avère que les intentions
sont de très très souvent voire la
majeure partie des cas suivie d'effet et
donc je pense qu'il faut ce dispositif
canto aux autres mesures qui ne sont pas
dans la loi le ministre nous a expliqué
hier longuement qui avait des tas de
mesures réglementaires qui avait été
prise pour pour éviter le pire en la
matière donc je crois que cet article
est nécessaire et que le débat le mot le
montrera donc cet amendement est assez
simple cet amendement de précisions avis
de la commission c'est le président la
criminal sion d'articles 5 résulte d'un
cumul qui permet le respect du principe
de l'égalité les 6,6 et des peines en
particulier l'entraînement aux
informations évoquées par présente
amendements devront se combiner outre le
projet terroriste avec le fait de
rechercher ou détenir des substances
dangereuses
dès lors une telle précision n'apparaît
pas nécessaire il ya pas un élément il
ya plusieurs éléments forcément donc si
on met dans chaque texte
oui mais sauf exception parce que la
formation etc
non c'est pas nécessaire franchement
aucun aucun procureur ou aucun juge dira
poursuivre quelqu'un parce que il ya une
formation mais s'il n'y a pas de but ou
d'autres éléments
il n'y aura pas de poursuites non je
vous demande de retirer votre amendement
autrement ça sera un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
mettre aux voix des explications de vote
pas donc pas la moule et je disais je
vais le retirer les explications du
rapporteur et du mini sont suffisantes
merci l'amendement ait retiré je vais
passer à l'amendement numéro 76 du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre bien
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
commission des lois enrichit la
rédaction de l'incrimination
d'entreprise terroristes individuels par
un nouveau fait matériel ainsi rédigé
effectuer des préparatifs logistiques
permettant de mettre en oeuvre les
moyens de destruction mentionnés aux a
cette rédaction répond à la nécessité de
viser dans les actes matériels
l'ensemble des comportements ou des
situations qui permettent de mener à
bien le projet terroriste
cependant en visant expressément les
moyens matériels
distinguent de ceux visés au à cette
rédaction a pour effet de supprimer
l'exigence du cumul de deux éléments
matériels distinctes dès lors que le
fait d'effectuer les préparatifs
logistiques et déjà compris dans le fait
de détenir de rechercher de se procurer
ou de fabriquer des objets ou substances
de nature à créer un danger pour autrui
aussi cet amendement tout en conservant
la démarche de la commission des lois on
améliore la rédaction en distinguant
clairement ce qui relève de l'élément
matériel indispensable qui est visé aux
as de ce qui relève de l'élément
matériel alternatif visés à l'alinéa 11
ce nouvel élément matériel pourra
consister par exemple en l'achat ou la
location de matériels de boxe ou encore
de véhicules avis de la commission comme
miss a bien voulu noté nous avons
ajoutées notamment la préparation
logistique c'est important on a vu un de
location de box etc
mais ça ne collait plus parfaitement
avec l'articulation de l'article est
donc la précision est utile pour
préserver le cumul non c'est un avis
favorable
pas d'explications de vote
je n'en vois pas je mets aux voix
l'amendement 76 qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient l'amendement est
adopté je suis hésite de trois
amendements en discussion commune le
numéro 47 de madame benbassa peut-être
défendre et vous le 48 en même temps ma
chère collègue
pour le 47 donc l'alinéa 2 de l'article
5 permet de considérer comme relevant de
l'entreprise terroristes individuels
la consultation de sites provoquant au
faisant l'apologie d'actes de terrorisme
il revient de fait 1,5 sionnel la
consultation habituelle de sites
terroristes
en considérant qu'il s'agit d'un acte
préparatoire à l'élaboration d'un acte
terroriste
il élargit également cette entreprise
terroriste individuelle à la détention
de documents provocante au terrorisme ou
en faisant l'apologie pour inclure
notamment les livres cet alinéa fait
appel à des notions floues incertaine
voire contraire au principe de l'égalité
de proportionnalité et recouvre donc des
situations très large
actuellement seule la consultation
d'image un pédo pornographique peut être
puni de deux ans de prison
pénalisé la consultation de contenu
idéologique ou la possession douvres âge
est une innovation qui pose de
nombreuses questions notamment en
matière de constitutionnalité et de
conventionalité il convient donc d'être
raisonnable et de supprimer cet alinéa 6
par curiosité intellectuelle
je consulte un site de ce genre
donc je serai taxe est de
terrorisme en vain c'est une
simplification certes mais ça peut
arriver
alors là peut-être il faudrait qu'on
réfléchisse sur ce cet amendement qui me
semble assez peu propice pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
quant à l'amendement 48 il s'agit d'un
amendement de repli ne concernant que
l'apologie des actes de terrorisme
l'article 4 de la présente loi distingue
clairement les délit d'apologie et de
provocation au terrorisme la
consultation de contenus faisant
l'apologie du terrorisme si elle est
bien sûr condamnable ne peut être
assimilable au terrorisme au même degré
que la consultation de sites provoquant
terrorisme le fait de consulter des
sites ou de posséder des ouvrages
faisant l'apologie d'actes de terrorisme
si odieux soit il ne saurait
caractériser à lui seul la préparation
d'un acte de terrorisme
contrairement à la consultation de sites
provocante au terrorisme merci merci
madame benbassa l'amendement numéro 12
de madame boulet il n'est pas défendu
donc avis de la commission sur cet
amendement numéro 47
oui madame à présent contrairement à ce
qui est avancé par les auteurs
d'amendements l'article 12 n'incrimine
pas en tant que tel la consultation
habituelle des sites faisant l'apologie
du terrorisme puisque seuls
l'association de ce groupe de ce
comportement avec les autres éléments
prévus par l'article permettra de
constituer le délit
donc c'est un avis défavorable il en est
de même on peut faire presque le même
commentaire pour l'amendement 47
oui 47 et 48 le puisque ce n'est pas la
consultation des sites qui permettra de
constituer l'infraction à elle seule
donc pour tous ces motifs je suis
défavorable maintenant si vous il faut
lire l'ensemble de l'article chers
collègues trop mal c'est pas il ya aucun
risque
y'a aucun risque
merci madame boulet voulez-vous
descendre votre abonnement
c'est un amendement de principe le
président je vous remercie de ce
rattrapage mais en fait il s'agit de la
consultation et de la détention qui
résulte de l'exercice normal de la
profession mais comme monsieur le
rapporteur et monsieur le ministre me
l'ont expliqué à l'alinéa précédent et
que je comprends relativement vite sans
qu'il soit besoin de m'expliquer
plusieurs fois j'ai l'impression que
ceux ci que ceux ci aient déjà
sous-entendu et donc je vais le retirer
merci madame le président merci ma chère
collègue monsieur le ministre votre avis
sur le 45t l'eau 48 s'il vous plaît mais
là mais c'est la triste benbassa votre
amendement est inspiré si je puis me
permettre par une idée fausse à une
contre-vérité non mais se permet de vous
le dire non c'est pas moi qui ai
toujours raison je dis simplement quel
est l'état du droit
et quel est le contenu de cet article
vous dites que la consultation de sites
appelant terrorisme provocante héroïsme
suffit à constituer la crazy de la
criminal sion pénale 2
d'actes terroristes individuels
c'est faux c'est tout simplement faux ce
qui caractérise et ouvre la grille
mination pénale c'est une cumulation
d'éléments c'est à dire celui ci plus
d'autre donc lorsque vous dites que
votre amendement est justifiée par le
fait que la simple consultation de sites
pourraient justifier d'une incrimination
pénale
c'est faux donc comme cela n'est pas
exact et qu' il faut plusieurs éléments
pour que la fraction soit constitué je
pense que votre crainte n'est pas fondée
je vous donne toutes garanties
ce sera inscrit au compte rendu et par
conséquent je vous propose de retirer
votre amendement
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
mettre aux voix cet amendement y at il
des explications de vote madame benbassa
monsieur le ministre j'ai tout à fait
confiance en vous je joue c'est
humaniste est déterminé à lutter contre
le terrorisme mais il faut pas avoir la
mémoire courte
ce sera pas toujours ça peut être un
autre régime et je peux avoir des lip
alpes on peut appliquer la même loi par
exemple je peux m'acheter des livres
gauchiste ensuite
consulté des sites révolutionnaire alors
est ce que cette loi s'applique par mois
on a l'impression qu'on regarde toujours
les événements qui se passe aujourd'hui
est pas se dire que demain cette loi
pourrait être appliqué à d'autres gens
il faut pas qu'on ait la mémoire courte
quand même on est on a fait de
l'histoire
on sait ce qui ce se qui se passe
lorsque la liberté d'expression est
limitée
c'est vrai je vous fais lire mais moi je
ne ris pas vous voyez merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président la
commission vous avez demandé la parole
merci madame la présidente
ma chère collègue nous avons un texte
qui est en fait assez clair il ne vise
pas à interdire un chercheur de chercher
il faut le cumul de deux faits
premièrement et c'est écrit aux petits
tas le fait de détenir de rechercher de
se procurer ou de fabriquer des objets
ou des substances de nature à créer un
danger pour autrui
vous avez parfaitement lu ce petit à
puisque vous avez présenté des
amendements soit pour le supprimer
soit pour le modifier 7
un premier élément qui doit
obligatoirement être constitué pour
qu'ensuite on y ajoute pour que
l'incrimination soit de complètement
constitué un deuxième élément
l'un des autres éléments matériels
suivants dit le petit b et parmi ses
autres éléments matériels
il y a celui qui consiste à consulter
habituellement un ou plusieurs services
de communication publique en ligne ou de
détenir des documents provoquant
directement à la commission d'actes de
terrorisme
donc chers collègues le danger que vous
voulez
évitez en présentant un amendement de
suppression de ce paragraphe qui relève
du petit b il est évitée par la
rédaction même de cet article qui
suppose le cumul de deux choses
autrement dit le chercheur lui il n'a
rien à craindre de ces dispositions si
vous voulez le protéger et bien le texte
le protège déjà voilà ce que je voulais
vous préciser en vous demandant mon cher
collègue de retirer votre amendement
parce que en réalité il est pourvu par
le texte lui même
y at il d'autres explications de vote
vous maintenez votre mandement macha
collègues
donc je vais le mettre aux voix qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adoptée même vote pour le
48 même vote
il n'est pas adopté nous allons
maintenant repasser à vote de l'article
donc je vais m non non non monsieur vous
madame boulet a retiré son amendement
je vais mettre aux voix l'article 5 du
projet de loi y at il des explications
de vote
je n'en vois pas je mets donc aux voix
l'article 5 qui et pour qui et contre
l'article 5 abstentions
pardon deux abstentions
l'article 5 est adopté voilà pour
l'adoption de ces deux articles phare du
projet de loi renforçant les moyens de
la lutte contre le terrorisme texte
défendu présenté par le ministre de
l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve mercredi
et hier jeudi au sénat un texte qui a
été très largement adopté par les
sénateurs
hier en fin d'après midi avec 317 voix
pour et seulement 28 voix contre on le
voit une véritable unanimité droite
gauche socialistes centristes et ump
pour ce texte qui s'inscrit dans une
situation d'urgence celle de la lutte
contre le jihad et celle de la montée en
puissance de l'état islamique
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les séances notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
oh